good morning I'm delighted to introduce
our next speaker
Keith Locke it's a great friend of mine
personally but also a great friend of
the University and of the Heinz College
Keith is a distinguished alumnus of the
Heinz College a member of my Dean's
Advisory Council and a member of the
Board of Trustees
he's also Co CEO of Salesforce and
member of their board of directors keith
serves and has served in a number of
important roles
he's the company's vice shamon president
and as a director since joining the
company in June 2013 and additionally he
served as the company's chief operating
officer since February 2016 clearly a
multi-dimensional multi-talented person
as president and CEO of Salesforce
Heath oversaw the company's
multibillion-dollar global sales and
services business alliances and channels
industry strategy corporate development
corporate affairs marketing and business
operations in February 2018 Keith and
his wife Suzanne established the block
Center for technology and society at CMU
this important center which is
cross-cutting in university wide will
foster critical dialogue on campus to
create inclusive and meaningful plans of
action on topics such as the future of
work and issues of trust and
transparency in the use of autonomous
systems to improve the quality of life
for all Keith's holds a Master of
Science degree in management and policy
analysis from the Heinz College and a
bachelor's degree in Information Systems
from Dietrich College so he was a head
even then at being at those nexus of
technology in society in addition to his
membership on the Carnegie Mellon
University Board of Trustees he's also
currently a member of the World Economic
Forum's Information Technology can be
as a governor and on the advisory board
of our Heinz College and its board of
trustees of the Concord Museum please
join me in welcoming Keith lock to the
podium
[Applause]
well thank you krishnan you've made me
blush this morning so I appreciate that
and thank you very much for that very
kind introduction so first I want to say
good morning everybody
okay that was my best Farnum I gave it a
run my friend anyway good morning to
everybody
faculty alumni staff family and friends
it is an honor to be here today to
celebrate the investiture of a great man
dr. Farnum Jahan e'en as president of
Carnegie Mellon University in all of
life's endeavors Farnum has led with a
tremendous spirit in an unrivaled
dedication whether as a world-renowned
computer scientist a passionate
successful entrepreneur a tireless
public servant or a world-class leader
in higher education and oh by the way
just an incredible incredible human
being now I've had the opportunity to
work very closely with Farnum and we
have shared many experiences around
career and our life journeys including
everybody's favorite Parenthood and
Farnam by the way that advice you gave
me about curfews for teenage kids thank
you so much for that I would never have
thought of that myself but thank
goodness it worked over the years we've
had a very very close relationship and
friendship and for that I'm very very
grateful professionally I've also had
the opportunity to observe Furnham in
his influence and guiding policy at the
World Economic Forum and I will tell all
of you he has represented this
university incredibly well I've also
witnessed his leadership here at CMU
personally with students and faculty and
staff and members of the board of
trustees and whether it's uniting the
community to support the special
olympics where i understand he has a
passion for dunk tanks do you just want
to come up and tell everybody about this
down time all right I'm sure you'll get
to that at some point
or really fostering engagement between
students from different colleges Farnum
has a talent a true talent for bringing
people together and breaking down walls
Farnum is also a leader with impeccable
integrity and the highest of character
he conducts himself with grace and
dignity and thoughtfulness and warmth
there is no question no question Farnum
will guide this institution into the
future and accelerate its impact on the
world so today we witnessed the passing
of a torch to an incredibly talented
individual
now this torch has been held by many
many great leaders throughout Carnegie
Mellon's very rich history and there
have been so many accomplishments and so
many historic milestones since Andrew
Carnegie founded a Technical School in
1900 individuals of great character and
honor have taken the reins of leadership
of this very prestigious institution and
each of them have led with courage and
vision names like Hammer slag Daugherty
stiver sire Cohen those are but a few
each of these presidents and others of
this storied institution led through
myriad chapters in American history
world history the turn of the century
the Great Depression the explosion of
Technology that Jim was talking about
just a few minutes ago
civil unrest war and peace and
throughout all of this presidents of
Carnegie Mellon have guided this
institution to the forefront of
educational excellence and they have
shaped the minds of so many young people
all the while ensuring that the
university remained a source of
inspiration a guiding light a beacon of
hope and now we pass this torch to
Farnum Jehan Ian
there was no one who was better suited
to lead us into the next chapter and
this next chapter is arguably the most
important ever for we do live in very
very interesting times we have seen and
this is just the beginning
but we have seen incredible advances in
technology we are at the dawn of
New Era some referred to it as the
fourth Industrial Revolution and this is
where we have the convergence the
perfect storm of social and mobile in
deep learning and artificial
intelligence and 3d printing and amazing
technologies all brought together to
drive incredible innovation now like
many of you I have the opportunity and
good fortune to speak with other CEOs
and world leaders and when as top of
mind in that group is how to harness
this wave of innovation in a very
positive way this convergence of
technology is having a profound impact
on our world you see it in our daily
lives
it has also brought great disruption and
given rise to many many questions what
will these new technologies be will they
be positive for mankind what are the
socio-economic effects what are the
privacy implications what will be the
regulatory issues what will be the
future of work and Farnam is passionate
about these questions and even more
passionate about CMU leading the way to
drive those answers to these questions
these are all important issues of our
time that we have to consider in a
thoughtful and meaningful and measured
way we are clearly at an inflection
point these advances must be for good
they must enlighten they must empower
and they must take humanity to greater
heights
and in a world where there is an
ever-increasing divide these advances
must create opportunity for all not just
a few so that all of mankind can
participate and contribute now this will
take vigilance it will take dedication
and it will take leadership and this is
why the faculty the staff the students
this community at Carnegie Mellon are so
critical to the future of this nation
this society this world for the young
minds that we shape here have an
important mission they will go forth
into the world with the knowledge the
vision and the ethics that Carnegie
Mellon has instilled in them and they
will go forward into the world to solve
universal issues that lie at the
intersection of
ecology and humanity the graduates of
CMU must be equipped to thrive and lead
in the world of uncertainty for these
are truly uncertain times today the
value of trust is being questioned more
than ever
trust in technology trust in our
institutions trust in our leaders some
would say there is a crisis of trust and
this crisis of trust has created a
leadership void and now individuals and
companies and faculty and students alike
must fill this breach and it will be the
graduates of CMU that will answer this
call for leadership and for them it is a
call to arms it is a call to arms for us
all it is an obligation to lead in an
ethical and transparent way to engage in
constructive civil discourse where
disagreements will arise and that's okay
but dialogue must happen with respect
and while there can be differing
opinions there cannot be differing facts
and most important most important to
restore trust in our society because
without trust
we have nothing it will be the graduates
of Carnegie Mellon that will be called
upon to cultivate and drive a culture of
success in business and society where
the core tenants of diversity empathy
equality humanity accountability and
opportunity for all are at the forefront
never before has this institution been
more important to the world never before
has leadership at the intersection of
technology and society and humanity been
as critical as it is right now and
though the future is unwritten I am very
confident very confident that the
graduates of CMU will be the authors of
a great future for all of us now as we
stand at the doorstep of this new world
the dawn of a new era
we need a truly special leader to help
guide and shape the lives of those who
will determine the future all of our
futures and never before has a
presidency of this institution been as
important as it is right now and it
requires a remarkable leader a truly
outstanding human being and that person
is doctor Farnum Jahan e'en we stand
with Farnum today as he takes his
a place amongst the great presidents of
Carnegie Mellon I cannot imagine a
better leader who embodies the values of
CMU I cannot imagine a better leader
with as much vision with as much passion
with as much focus and I cannot imagine
a better leader in torchbearer of this
great institution Farnham we are very
lucky to have you
you are the right leader as Jim says at
the right time so ladies and gentlemen
please join me in congratulating a true
friend a great leader and the next
president of Carnegie Mellon University
dr. Farland Ahana
[Applause]